i need to say a word or two
in light of the fact that there is what
we will talk about an industrial
strength
campaign to censor this story and i need
to say something rather directly to
those who are most likely to attempt to
censor it
what i want to say is that dr corey
is not only an advocate for a therapy
that is incredibly useful in the context
of covet 19
but he is also someone who has pioneered
therapies already that are now the
standard of care for
covet 19 patients that means he has
earned the right to talk about whatever
he thinks is important
for my part as you know i was also
very early on the lab leak hypothesis
and i was very careful about how i
presented it and of course in the last
month
that hypothesis has been vindicated
everyone including dr ralph barrick who
is the leading
expert in the world on bat born
coronaviruses and their modification in
the lab has acknowledged
that a leak from the lab in wuhan china
is
plausible i have also earned the right
to talk about what i want to talk about
and what i think is necessary
we are now going to have a conversation
and if you don't like it
that youtube is your problem we are
entitled to discuss this because
a lot depends on it and what we do when
issues are complex is we hash them out
and figure out what's true through
dialectic so that's what we're going to
do
i do want to talk to you a little bit
about what it looked like
as you as a lung specialist and icu
specialists were encountering covid
patients and coming to understand what
they were really sick with rather i mean
i remember the early days of the
pandemic and the sort of groping for
reason why do the symptoms
look like this right is it a lung
disease is it a blood disease
what is it so what did happen with these
patients what did you realize about them
yeah so sorry about um
uh clear my throat but you know it was
clearly you know what was clearly
recognized early on is that it was a
disease of phases right so it started
out as a general viral syndrome
most people recovered self-limited and
it's like a cold right sometimes a
little
a little bit more severe than a cold but
everyone quickly realized that around
day
five 7 8 there was a proportion of
patients who
suddenly started dropping their oxygen
levels and basically their lungs were
inflamed and we now know that it's a
cell called a macrophage
which gets activated and literally
attacks the lungs and so you have this
sort of immune response that is
attacking the lungs and the lungs start
to fail
so a macrophage is like an amiibo-like
cell that goes around basically garbage
collected yes that was a little
scavenger
there's a scavenger cell so it was
attached to the front line it's the
front line of defense right and so
yeah and it goes into the lungs and it
causes
a lot of inflammation and so that
inflammation injures the lung
and so you could see the lungs not
starting not to work and so it's
predominantly a severe lung disease and
and what i
will never forget in my life is those
early months because
and i'm going to go back to that steroid
thing we saw
patients just this disease marching
straight to the ventilator
and so many people were landing on
ventilators and you remember
people were running out of ventilators
and there was two reasons for that
one is because the entire healthcare
community
globally said this is a viral disease
so supportive care only you're talking
about tylenol
and fluids and as they did supportive
care only because there was no
randomized controlled trials letting no
dude like
everyone talk about evidence space i'm
always like what about
experience based medicine like i've been
doing this for 30 years why can't i do
what my experience tells me to do i
don't have randomized controlled trials
but
to do nothing was leading to ventilator
shortages
okay i want to clear one thing up for my
audience who won't be familiar with
the terminology and then make a point
about what you've just said the first
thing
is uh what did you call this a policy of
tylenol and supportive care
so the idea here is that historically
speaking
we have had very little to do about
viruses yes we've been
tremendously effective with antibiotics
against
bacteria against fungi they don't
in general work against viruses and
antiviral therapies have been a dicey
business for a long time
what does work has been vaccines
but if you get to a pandemic and you
don't have a vaccine
what you were effectively being told is
look there's not a whole lot of positive
intervention you can do
so let's just make them comfortable
rescue them if they need to be rescued
but other than that
kind of hands off but here's the here's
here's one of the mistakes so
it is correct to say we don't have good
antiviral therapies
it's incorrect to say that they were
dying of the virus
we knew relatively early on by the time
they get to the icu
and they're that sick there's not a lot
of viral replication going on in fact
you can't culture virus after about day
seven or eight
and so it's actually disease of
inflammation not viral invasion in fact
in autopsy series
only 20 percent do they find what's
called cytopathic changes from the virus
into the lung and so it wasn't
you didn't have to go after the virus at
that point you had to actually check the
inflammation okay so again i want to do
a little translation for the audience
so inflammation and by the way this is a
place where i would take doctors to task
but
doctors often treat something like
information as if it's inflammation as
if it's simply bad
the fact is inflammation is an
adaptation yes that often gets out of
control and it can
easily kill you right over exuberant
right so we have to bring it into check
yes
yes so what you're telling me is that
coveted patients were infected with the
virus it triggered
a pathway that is part of healing but
triggered an overreaction and the
patients
who were dying on these ventilators
weren't really dying of the virus being
so very active
they were dying of this cascade of
events that follows
the body's attempt to fight off a
pathogen it's never seen it was a
reaction to
in fact one of the most impressive
studies um
that paul actually highlighted is that
they what we think triggers the
inflammation is actually the viral
debris it's the rna
that actually has this it triggers this
massive response to the body so it's not
the virus it's actually the debris of
the dead virus that does it so it's
well let me uh flag something for
the future my advisor
who's now gone guy named dick alexander
used to talk
um about the point in a uh
in a a respiratory illness when you stop
coughing on behalf of your virus and
start coughing on your own behalf
and the point he was making was that
actually
the these pathogens necessarily induce
changes that cause them to be passed on
so they will
create irritation they will create
inflammation they will create
all kinds of phenomena that are symptoms
that are actually
basically the the ecology that allows
them to
transmit right and so in a sense
i don't know why it's the viral debris
but there's a pretty good chance that
this
virus learned that by creating debris it
could cause a lot of stuff to accumulate
in the lungs that got ejected in some
chaotic way
who knows it could be yeah so i didn't
deal with it that way yeah it's worth
thinking about
but the other point i i wanted to make
in reference uh to
your sense as a clinician that you were
you know effectively having your hands
tied behind your back when you knew a
whole lot about patients and were
learning more every day
right you needed to be freed to try
things and
the point i would make is once upon a
time
before we were born doctors were
scientists yes
they had fewer tools but what they had
was a whole lot of experience and even i
want to bring attention to the house
call which has now effectively gone
extinct
but the house call allowed a doctor who
didn't have
a huge range of pharma
pharmacological agents or tools at his
disposal but
what he did have was the ability to
observe
patterns right so if people on one side
of town were sick with something and
people on the other side of town
weren't maybe there was something in the
water for example so anyway that ability
to observe
patterns was part of a scientific
mindset that
my impression having interacted with
doctors over my lifetime
is that that mindset has basically
dwindled
you know i love that you're going back
because i love the history of medicine
and when i read
stuff from 100 years ago you're
constantly shocked by how much they knew
with very little of i mean they don't
have the experience you know the
experiments or the
the techniques to discover what now we
know
they did it all by powers of observation
just and
really medicine was created by the best
doctors who had the keenest powers so
the
giants of medicine had these
unbelievable powers of observation
and they were able to do a lot and and
that's why i always say to my students i
always say
that what separates sort of them from me
it's we've read the same books we all
have
you know the textbooks i said but an
expert has pattern recognition you just
see
diseases play out you see how different
people react the same illnesses and you
just get to see patterns and patterns
and
and what happened to me i love talking
about this but
you know every time i came to the
bedside of a patient there was something
wrong with them i always had to very
deliberately kind of analyze like it
could be this
this this and after about a couple of
years being immersed in icu medicine
i noticed that i could now walk into a
room
and just like with very little
information just kind of know what was
going on it suddenly became like
intuitive and second nature and it was
all just about
observing patterns and so i think that's
really key and
and that's why with this disease like i
this is not an ego exercise but
we knew you had to anticipate these
patients within like four patients
like we knew they were clotting to
degrees that we hadn't seen and
there was so much controversy around
putting someone on a blood thinner which
people are put on blood thinners in
hospitals for
far less reasons than we were promoting
with this
and so it was just evidence-based
maniacism it was bizarre they
like now you can't observe you can't
make clinical reasoning you can't deduce
you need a trial before you do anything
okay so this is
i must tell you exactly the same in my
field right the people who are really
good
uh evolutionary biologists or ecologists
evolutionary ecologists in the best
cases um have
intuition they know how to follow a
hunch they know how to figure out when
their hunches are wrong
yes right the point is it's a it's an
art more than a science actually no
question
and in the case of a brand new pandemic
that is spreading like wildfire this is
of course
exactly the mindset that you want you
want people who are capable
of deducing that there is some pattern
and then figuring out whether they were
fooled by
some sort of uh noise pattern or whether
it was actually something
testing a hypothesis but there is a
point at which you know
and you know better than a study because
you know you've acted on that hunch and
you've seen that the patients get better
and it happens enough times that it
can't be random
and so anyway there's something about
the mindset of the moment
in which it's all about peer review
and these published peer-reviewed papers
and it's all about the official guidance
from you know the who and the cdc and
it's basically a kind of
intellectual authoritarianism that is so
bizarre in the context of a complex
system like medicine
especially in the context of a brand new
disease that
you know we're all not experts and there
are no experts that we can simply
default to
everybody's you know a novice i'd like
that term
intellectual authoritarianism because
and it it actually
although i don't know that it was
occurring to this degree or even
remotely to this degree pre-covert i i
actually i looked around in coven and i
started to see like
all the institutions coming up with
their treatment protocols you
weren't allowed to stray from the
protocol even like if you're an expert
and you're like i want to like
literally the leaders of the hospitals
were saying
don't use and you couldn't do anything
else you couldn't actually doctor and
suddenly i felt like
i was being handcuffed well it was
bizarre i've never seen that in my life
before i have the sense that doctors
have been demoted
forcibly demoted from the position of
scientific clinician
to technician and the point is you're
really delivering a prepackaged good
more than you are uh coming to
understand your patient and what they're
sick with and what they therefore need
and it's a travesty i've never been
asked to do that before i've always been
asked to
use the the best extent of my experience
and judgment and insight
to best help the patient that's the oath
i took the oath it wasn't
due what the gods of science and that we
paul calls the uh the the healthcare
leaders the gods of science and
knowledge right because
this sort of you know we're just little
mortals and we have to listen to the
gods and
and i've never been asked that before to
to to
to get advice from oftentimes i'm sorry
but i don't want to sound so dismissive
but
many of them are really desk jockeys i
mean they're not on the front lines i
mean
they're reading some papers they think
they know what the disease is they don't
know what this disease is
they're not sweating it out seeing
day-to-day
the manifestations the responses to
therapy the lack of responses
they don't understand this disease and
yet they're telling everyone how to
treat it and i find it
we want a seat at the table expert
clinicians where's the expert clinician
committee
right i absolutely agree and you know
you see that at the level of doctoring i
see that at the level of
the pandemic itself yes right the fact
is
we have a novel phenomenon it came
potentially from an unusual source
right a knowable source potentially what
we are supposed to do about it to
actually
um take care of it so that it does not
become a permanent fellow traveler of
humanity
that takes really smart insightful
courageous people who have been totally
liberated
to have whatever discussions need to be
had instead
we're in this situation where if we open
our mouths and say the wrong
word suddenly there are warnings
appended to what we've said
it's insane it's limiting discussion
limiting choices limiting
approaches it's hard yes it's
and i don't know do we did we all forget
the history books that we read like
when is censorship ever been a good
thing yeah when are the sensors ever the
good guys
when is that ever led to a societal good
right you know
well that that is i mean i i i
really hope that uh whatever thing it is
inside of youtube and twitter and
facebook and
linkedin that has its meetings i hope
they look at this
and they sit down and somebody in the
room is courageous enough to look at
everybody else and say
are we the bad guys in the story and if
so how did that happen
like i get the intention
right so you want to protect people
because medical
misinformation might harm them but what
i find
i have two problems with that which is
who's the
who's gonna you know if you're gonna
limit science i mean science
that's the antithetical to science
science is about exploration
hypotheses and scientists never
discovered
at the nih building right it's actually
the people on the ground doing
experiments making deductions
we should flow the information to them
not flow information
so so that is that and then the placing
of medical misinformation
on a par with like violent hate speech
white supremacy like i'm sorry but
medical
you know it's not as harmful as you
would think
i mean you know people are afraid that
you need to espouse some
medicine that's not going to work and
they're going to hurt someone
i i think people do not need to be
protected to that extent i mean people
have
judgment they do lots of things in the
world you know what i'm saying like
censorship's not the answer to that